ever I feel like this is a this is one  of the first times in history that the  weak have governed the strong well yeah  yeah like the tech overlords right so  like so these guys generally are like  the weaklings but they were intelligent  right and normally we lived in a society  where Alpha men would take over like  Nations right with armies and stuff but  it's no longer that the the the the the  Revolution and the Takeover is now in an  intellectual one yeah a lot of the time  strength doesn't it doesn't matter in  that situation what matters is how how  much you can out-think the opponent and  so a lot of the time now in these in  these days and times the the weak and  our governing the strong